STEPHANIE WONG: Hi.
I'm Stephanie.
And today, I'll show
you how Google Cloud's
visual inspection
products can help
you improve the efficiency
of the manufacturing
visual quality
control processes.
In the world of manufacturing,
current market volatility
leads to huge
operational pressures.
You're first in line
to respond quickly
to decreased demand,
disruption in the supply chain,
and interrupted retail channels.
Business continuity
becomes P zero,
and the weight of reducing
costs falls on your shoulders.
Naturally, leveraging AI
to improve work efficiency
becomes the light at
the end of the tunnel
as you start to explore more
ways to advance automation,
control manufacturing
processes remotely,
and enable a remote workforce.
In the last several years,
visual inspection technologies
have been helping
manufacturers ease
these operational pressures.
Image recognition is being
used for electronic part
classification, retail quality
assurance, and even food
inspection.
Yet, it can be difficult
and costly to implement
these technologies.
Traditional inspection
machinery can cost
millions of dollars per device.
Setting up and deploying
AI for inspection
not only needs a reliable
IT infrastructure and expert
resources, but there's usually
a limited amount of sample data
to start with.
On top of that,
training ML models
can be extremely
challenging, time consuming,
and can require a specialized
skill set that not
all companies have access to.
Take these defective
parts, for instance.
Factory workers are
often tasked with finding
these discrete defects
on the production line.
These small marks can
be extremely subtle,
making it hard for even a
human eye to be able to see.
It's no surprise that
this process can be
time consuming and inefficient.
This is why Google Cloud
has a rich offering
for visual inspection
products, which
reduces the pressure on ground
workers and AI developers
and increases time to value.
It optimizes for several
steps at the visual inspection
process from data ingestion to
production model optimization.
Google Cloud's visual
inspection products do this
by enabling customers
to efficiently
pre-process minimal
images for model training,
then it augments the data
and trains automatically,
so you can quickly
deploy the model locally
and run inferencing at
the production line.
Better yet, you can
continuously improve the model
by using fresh data collected
from production lines
to retrain the model
in the cloud giving you
increased accuracy as you
discover new use cases.
Here's what an end-to-end
architecture would look like.
Once a camera is set up
on the production line,
users can collect
images and store them
on the factory floor server.
From here, the
images are uploaded
to Google Cloud using the visual
inspection AI products to begin
model training.
Let's say you want to
inspect an assembled product
to find defective components
like damaged glass on devices.
Labeling thousands of
devices is probably
the last thing you want to do.
Instead, using Google Cloud's
visual inspection AI products,
you can upload images for
a new product component,
and the solution
can automatically
extract this component after
you label a few images.
The model will analyze
all loaded images
to automatically identify the
subset of the data with defects
or anomalies.
Along the way, you have a
chance to review current model
performance for
defect detection using
built-in metrics, like
average precision, precision,
and recall.
After downloading and
deploying the trained model,
inferencing can be
efficiently done locally
on your factory floor for
rapid edge performance.
And when an unlabeled
image comes in,
the deployed model can predict
new defects automatically.
Results can then be viewed
in the central cloud
dashboard giving prediction
details and a place
to correct inspections.
Using Google Cloud's
visual inspection products
you can train
customized ML models
in the cloud with minimum
amount of label images,
leverage scalable
cloud infrastructure
for distributed training
and optimize costs,
enable production workloads
within weeks versus months,
efficiently deploy
models, and run
inferencing at production lines
on-premise for low latency.
And it's not just useful
for automating the detection
of defective devices.
Google Cloud's visual
inspection products
can support a wide range of
discrete manufacturing use
cases, such as cosmetic
defect detection and Edge
detection for electronics,
surface quality
control for automotives,
optical wave for a defect
detection for semiconductors,
and fabric or packaging quality
control for consumer
packaged goods.
Using Google Cloud's
visual inspection products,
you can increase the throughput
and efficiency of your ML
models, improve
overall operations,
and augment your workers
ability to guarantee
the highest quality
products land
in the hands of your customer.
Reach out to your
Google Cloud rep
to learn how you can deploy
visual inspection solutions
using cloud AI products.
And visit the Google Cloud
Vision AI page to learn more
about our products.
[MUSIC PLAYING]